it's a very good point you know I think
I'm su still exist well obviously
because there's this fascination that
people want to actually come and see
different animals in captivity but I'd
like to say that zoos exist because they
have evolved people just want to go and
see animals that they don't see anywhere
else and from that point of view I think
the rarity of whatever species they're
looking at there's something called the
anthropogenic ally effect so something
is more valuable the less of it there is
especially when it comes to endangered
species and you see that with animal
collectors in the Far East for instance
and it's given us particular problems
with a species of tortoise called the
plowshare to us as it becomes sub 400 in
the wild they're worth more and more to
these collectives now to some extent
zoos are just an extension of that and
you can go and see an animal that you
just wouldn't see anywhere else and
people value that experience zoos are
good zoos or conservation centers now
good Sue's hold important conservation
species good zoos work in range
countries where these species are found
fighting for the preservation of those
species in the wild
that's why zoos exist
tell you what they need to exist more
they will be needed and called upon more
in the future Durrell as it stands
doesn't consider itself to be an
attraction you know we are a
conservation organization first and
foremost saving species from extinction
and teaching other people to do it and
actually I can't speak for too many
other zoos but here I know that this
offers the opportunity to train people
to date the pack and in combination with
the field programs has allowed us to
train somewhere near 4,100 people from
141 countries so these people often come
on scholarships sometimes they pay their
own way but they go back to their own
country with the knowledge and basically
with the information that we've been
able to provide from keeping animals for
as long as we have you know what
do one of the things we do as an
organization is enable the passionate
people on the ground to keep going you
know certainly the research that's been
done in zoos that have captive bred
species for conservation is critically
important to what you can then do in the
field for instance the tamarind species
that we work with here particularly the
pied tamarind has allowed I mean just
keeping them for 26 years has allowed us
to research what to keep them healthy
and happy and we've had a life
expectancies of twenty plus years in
sagres time tamarins that we've then
been able to take him to rescue centers
in Colombia and in Brazil and we've
managed to train the people look working
those rescue centers so that their life
expectancies have gone up from four
years to perhaps a decade or more and
they've become breeding centers now that
would have never happened had there not
been a zoo population of time of
tamarins to study so you can say that
whether or not they still have a place
as captive breeding centers certainly
you can learn more on your own doorstep
and take it back to the field when all
the pressure is off when you away from
any stochastic events such as disease or
fire or anything like you know
essentially an animal back here isn't
sanctuary so we have to look at captive
populations as animals that reside in
safe forest fragments if you like safe
reserves that are managed and if you
think about populations in the wild
lions tigers Mariah tangs monster at
mountain chickens
pay out pied cameron's you know there's
not much wild left there they're captive
in their own countries by the
fragmentation and deforestation around
them those patterns in those tiny forest
fragments in Manaus they're captive
there and they will unless nothing
nothing is done those fragments will be
discipline disappear so this is this
idea about the wild I think people need
to wake up when they're here in a zoo
this not so much of a problem
and there's always then the ability to
take that population back
you